hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the machine okay I got the
powder and I guess I can put the powder
in the cannon here can I use this item
this way maybe in the back huh what huh
choo choo mama Sarah
oh there's a little V I see oh wow
that's actually kind of intricate they
put this thing I recognize this from
like trying to extract stuff and I guess
it's in there now it's like in the
original game you put bone in there and
it would work that way so now I just got
to find a stone cannonball or something
or anything that could be used it whoa
lag spike what the hell anything that
could be used as ammo and see you wanna
do T sack up potaters nope loaf of bread
that could probably be some pretty good
ammo
nope Oh what's with this weird lag I
don't know there now okay there was
nothing in there was that so broken
bottle huh well where can I find some
stupid I know it said that the somewhere
it said that the thing was some about
diggable maybe I've had a journal entry
about it nope no mementos my last note
nope Oh what was this green rod yeah
blah blah okay okay oh behind there
someone said in the comments that you
can't dig it out with a shovel so what
the heck do I do that hmm what huh my
ash yeah hiding some right now oil
damn hmm yeah fine I'm using this oh
this rock oh this might actually work
nope too big good in there okay good get
in the front
yeah load it up did that work holy crap
I think it worked
close it up this fumbling in the dark
oh oh yeah holy crap what the heck did I
grab I just was like oh whatever grab
okay anyway making progress
oh boy
oh I'm headed towards the demonic circle
which always always a good thing
come back here new hey back here huh wha
huh wha no ah ah dark can't see okay
nothing on the table okay nothing at all
at all ah fu buddy you can't have me you
couldn't handle me anyway good boy
oh yes look that's just the machine
talking to me or the demon Mnet's huh uh
yeah it's a kind of even creature
kidding
ah a palpable bone what the heck oh no
is that my lady oh I guess the pictures
are supposed to represent who they are
otherwise why would they be their plant
blocked off okay therefore points there
were four body parts so there's
something mythical okay let me try
putting the body parts in the places can
I even pick up the body parts nope
that was stupid a bone maybe maybe take
the bone
hah yeah yeah did that work
I got a rock wonk wonk nope look going
this way anybody out there
hmm please to hide oh come on
what's with the lag really really
computer really computation machine oh
oh not water
oh not water I'm about to run out of
rent your honor uh I give me so many
sanity potions enough of oil or to the
boxes anything in there nope okay what's
this term Nina
in case of summoning failure I prepared
a pepper exorcism ritual to dismiss the
demon I am not sure if this work so be
careful requirement a one thing you love
not my computer a piece of pure evil not
my computer a piece of a really bad
thing that should work - not my computer
a jar full of blood must be of pure
blood an emerald gem all things must be
gathered around the main summoning
circle in the right order first two
things inside the round marks and the
rest inside the pentagram marks when
everything is only place The Exorcist
he must be a religious and righteous
person have to get inside the summoning
circle am i religious it is important
for him to carry a Holy Bible
otherwise the demon cat was his his
whole the main objective ethics with ego
is to recognize a demon's name only then
should the exercise exercise be able to
dismiss a mr. Paul okay so I need to
find out this demon's name
and then get a Bible to exorcise a demon
from machine hello chair goes along
there ah what's that oh just one of
those drawn Justine so I got a picture
of Nina right reminds me about my wife
is your wife named Nina then shut up
Whitney isn't it this news why put that
oh you read all right anything down
there
oh hello here nope nada there we go
Boyle oh but not enough not enough ha ha
ha no kidding oh hey you you know have
you buddy he's so thanks so foo ah yeah
good Bible here okay that's cool at all
I'll toss him down there boom yeah to
pump will happen that guy
Oh master the hmm oh ah that big - bigan
yes I don't know why the game needed to
tell me to run I played this game before
I am well of where when and how much I
should run in the face of those demons
oh come on oh I get it I need to go in
one out the other but not yet my needs
for this room here huh okay the picture
of Nina is something I love I just
realized that oh hello what that what
was that
sandy push I don't need sandy potion
Otto give me a give me a give me up no
I'm not sure I'm not sure ah good I'm so
good ah I can beat anything in this game
huh
what the hell happened
God how do we get out of here I guess I
am religious given how many references
I'm giving to God
what happened did that hurt
ow I did hurt oh and I have a slight
headache better take a sanity potion Oh
Boyle hello give me that oh yeah big
potion oh I like them big everyone knows
that oh boy oh boy I don't like this is
the perfect place for a water monster
make sure there's a hunk of blue over
there hmm
hmm I don't recall sewers like this in
the main game I swear that this guy
spent the time to make some extra
textures or not basic stuff oh okay I
got to break through that wall or
something
okay just a dinner box is that the only
thing
Oh what the heck was was it do what the
heck am I supposed to do
yeah huh all right um maybe if I find a
rock or something I can throw it at the
wall like that would do anything but who
knows we rock at it just gotta find a
rock run out of oil before I find
anything
I think nope
rockin the Neve thing above rock rock
rock better Rock no that's not right ah
well what the heck yeah throw my body
way that Oh hmm look a heck
um nothing above oh here we go is that a
rotten damn Rock well poop okay
I'm just gonna do this in quadrants tile
search everything in one place and then
eliminate it I don't see a damn thing
rocks nothing just a whole lot of water
this place has been searched I'm never
gonna come back here again looking
around looking around or anything oh
shut up no it's not damn okay
the hallway was searched place searched
[ __ ] Mouse out of oil again
okay this area with its wooden pillars I
don't see anything
nope nothing mister check water nothing
nothing at all
bollocks bleep bollocks
all right nothing in here well attack
huh that annoying
okay there's a dead body but that does
me no good okay um
whatever all right then well forget
Freddie Freck okay anyway I'm out of
time um if you know what I'm supposed to
do write in the comments so that I won't
get lost for the next episode but thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye-bye